you have had such an incredible eye for
talent over the course of your career he
mentioned a few of the of the Academy
award-winning filmmakers who started
with you but I came up with a list just
of directors who have made movies for
Roger over the years and the list reads
George Armitage Paul Bartel Peter
Bogdanovich James Cameron fantasy Ford
Coppola Joe Dante Jonathan Demi Curtis
Hanson monte hellman jack hill Ron
Howard Gale Anne Hurd jonathan kaplan
Nicolas Roeg john sayles martin scorsese
and robert towne that list is incredible
it's absolutely incredible so I think
with what everyone in the audience is
wondering I mean people in the audience
who are making movies and are looking
for new talent and then the younger
people in the audience who are beginning
their careers want to know what did what
did these people do to impress Roger
Corman and what did you see in them to
to give them these opportunities well
I'm a number of them were working as my
assistant Francis Coppola was my
assistant Jonathan Demi was my assistant
others were working in different
categories Ron Howard of course as an
actor met affect the one you didn't
mention people have got a nerve Kershner
was was a friend of mine as a matter of
fact her was a brilliant director he was
doing documentaries and the first film
in which I hired another director was
herb he went on to having a great career
he directed the second star wars for for
George Lucas was probably the peak of
his career well in addition to to your
eye for talent you've also had your
finger on the pulse of pop culture
throughout your career I mean you've
always managed to tap into genres at
exactly the right time and so we saw
some examples in the trailers we were
watching tonight of horror films that
you've made but also crime films
gangster films you've invented genres
like the motorcycle picture and car
chase films and you distributed and made
art house
and you even made family films films for
children correct over the course of your
that's correct I would like to salute my
wife who's died I was here tonight Julie
who has made a number of the successful
family films well so how have you how
have you decided or discerned when a
particular genre was would be popular
would be a box office success and and
and and how did you figure out when
maybe that genre was on the wane to a
certain extent it would be a genre that
appealed to me that I felt would appeal
to the public as well so it was a
combination of being aware of the
commercial potential of certain genres
and also being a genre I wanted to work
in for instance the wild angels which
you mentioned which was the first of the
Hells Angels film which was was the
opening night film at the venice film
festival complete with the condemnation
by the US State Department who have sent
out a statement that this was not
representative of American culture it
was I was told was the biggest grossing
independent film ever made it spawned a
whole group I would say there must have
been 50 motorcycle films in about seven
or eight film years and I didn't direct
anymore I directed the wild angels I
produced a couple of them and it follows
a cycle you start with something that's
nobody seen before like the wild angels
it does this and then other films come
in you build up a cycle and after a
certain period of time too many
motorcycles films are being made and
they drift down now that happened a
little bit with horror films horror
films were out of fashion when i made
the Fall of the House of Usher which was
the first of the Edgar Allan Poe films
the pit and the pendulum which you'll
see tonight was the second horror films
were at a low level one idea
uh sure it was successful they started
to build up and of course I can't claim
any originality for horror films that
have been made since films have been
made but cycle build up where the whole
group of horror films too many it
started to fall but because horror films
really do I believe affect the
unconscious mind and are a staple the
cycle goes like this it drops horror
films are out of style but then somebody
hits with a new version of a horror film
and the cycle builds builds back up
again